[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the 2019 st.
Louis norm Congress my name is Caleb ben
b i'm filling in here for Ben Simon
today and as always I'm joined by the
wonderful AG Alexander Linderman and so
let's take a look and see what we got
going on today see where we sit in the
standings and see what the players are
trying to do right so it looks like in
the GM section we still have
International Master Joel ban walk
sitting in first place a half point
ahead of the field and tied for a second
are you know three grandmasters so
they've already got their norms but
there is still here to play some good
chess and it's JJ Ali mirandy we got
Jackson buyuk Dennis Burroughs and also
topside barber Tommy Hahn who is not yet
a grandmaster and is hoping to score her
first norm here in st. Louis and so and
then rounding out the field we have
Justin weighing Brandon Jacobson Andrew
Hong Brian Escalante in Casa Corley so
with that said let's take a look at one
of the key matchups today between
Brandon Jacobson the one of the top
seeds in the tournament I was still an
iamb but very close to GM level and the
TFR Brahimi on who won two games in a
row including yesterday's dramatic win
against Casa Corley from a position
which seemed like was unwinnable but and
then you know I saw alive
you know her game against Andrew Hong
she played a very nice game she
outplayed him she played pretty well in
the complications and won a nice game so
let's see how this game goes so this was
the French the winner of French which is
TFO Brahimi Anne's Breton butter and
here she played a little bit of a
sideline v6 it's a line that I've even
played myself not committing to a quick
c5 because after c5 there are a lot of
lines like takes takes 97 queen g4 now
there's this famous poisoned pawn
variation Queen c7 takes here takes
there and let's say 92 and so on and so
forth with a bunch of heavy theory and
the line which I've seen that she have
played quite a few times and I've played
it myself
castles and then Bishop d3 Knight of
three and
so on and so forth where white tries to
get an attack black tries to plane the
queenside and this is also very sharp
line but here in this game a touch you
have decided to play three six which I
haven't seen her play that common but
it's certain a very viable sideline so
how does this serve to avoid the queen
g4 theory so now the idea is if white
goes Quincy four here a blacks idea
would actually be to play Bishop f8
where c5 hasn't been played the bishop
is not forced to trade for the night
just yet and then blood tries to keep
the game on a distance let's say ninety
seven c5 96 or maybe Bishop a6 trying to
exchange those bishops and try to play
like a long positional game right
interesting
so white played a3 another mainline
Bishop takes pawn takes and Queen d7 so
the idea of that move it might seem of
like a very clumsy move to everybody at
first but the idea is a prophylaxis
after queen g4 we're preparing for queen
g4 by meeting with with f5 we're
conveniently the Queen on g7
protects the spawn and g7 in a very nice
way so that's the main idea for example
if you go here right away
then queen chief or wood or maybe it
takes and then queen g4 would either
force g6 would which would you know
potentially produce a lot of weaknesses
like after this h4 h5 or you have to
move the Kings f8 which is not to
everyone's taste as well I think that
might be aligned to but Queen g7 is more
popular line right Quinn g4 a5 Queen g3
why doesn't want to take on the zone
helping black with the development so
white plays Queen g4 g3 this space 6 so
now this is still mainline theory age 6
h4 trying to secure the night on the for
preventing g5 and king of 7 which is you
know very clever move with idea of
defending the square and meeting this
with this I've actually seen this in
practice before I've even played this
myself before if I'm not mistaken Wow
what blocks so I actually know a little
bit about that line
a4 and that's you know typical move 97
black now has two ideas he either wants
to play c5 right away or he might want
to go knight c6 Knight a5 and control
this c4 outpost right h5 yes
so I'm just wondering about blacks night
on a six that looks a little bit out of
place for now it is but in the long run
you know black might want to go 98-96
but first okay he doesn't commit that
yet because he knows he needs to play
ninety seven anyway right then needs to
probably play c5 and then he'll decide
what a knight will do maybe it will be
more useful protecting the c5 square of
GC Knight 65 but maybe it will go 98 96
I will see it you know for example if
white would go Queen d3 then for sure
black would try something like this or
queen c8 followed by c5 okay so white
played h5 it's a good question though c5
lukkage 3 I'm not sure if white played
in the most testing way in this game
right but because I think black already
got a got a very good position rook c8
Quincy 398 look f3 or logical knight c6
so as you could see the knight now
reposition themselves nicely King e8
getting the king but sunflower attack
I'm sure Knight a5 first was also
possible with King eh should be okay
preparing for white to play chief or
white went for it broke a four-night of
5 so now you see the knight on these
seven found a knight another whole reign
of five Bishop e3 and this is where I
actually don't like that she has plan up
to here I think that she have played an
excellent game but this is where I think
that she's lost losing the thread a
little bit you see the knight on the 5
is already controlling you know a lot of
these light scores very nice so I don't
really see a point of going Knight c7
where you know basically the Knights are
duplicating each other they're redundant
they're both controlling the same
squares
whereas this Knight does an excellent
job here keeping White's counterplay at
bay and whites for example after move
like rook f8 why does not really
threaten to take because of Knight 65 so
I think I move like rook f8 getting the
last piece in the game yeah and after
this you know let's say rook f7 you know
black would that thing be very
comfortable here I would say black is
better sure maybe even King back to f7
and King g8 and you know actually
artificially castling keeping the knight
on c6 and but essentially trying to go
so I was wondering why not a queen f7
here for black with that we're and here
in some tonight c e7 o we know seven
instead yeah that's my 93 might have
been the point yeah that's a good
question also yes Iruka fate 93 then i
guess now you can go night c7 right let
them play 93 first and then you're going
to an IE 7 so again don't declare your
intention the knight on c6 for now has
flexibility you see it can go to a5 it
can go to e7 rockin H it has no other
prospects besides going to a fade so it
makes more sense to do what you need to
do anyway first right and then you know
you can decide on other things stay
flexible yeah but you know unfortunately
that you have played here and already
after a 5 this is becoming a little bit
more messy and even here perhaps instead
of queen c6 it was possible to do g5
takes on c4 and tried to Knight takes g6
and maybe try to do something with that
pool right but that's of course already
a little bit more messy so who in the
six is a human move but here already I
feel like whites getting different
counter play by the way Worthing not
worth note maybe it was worth flicking
in this intermediate move c4 you know
after which Queen d1 8 takes b6 but
instead a be queen a6 happen and there
were a couple or more moves played rugby
8 which may be awesome also isn't the
best maybe it was ready better to give
up the pawn this way and trade the
Queen's yes but rugby ADC and already on
so we could see it within 3-4 move
suddenly white black went from
comfortably I think better in my
position on my opinion so suddenly on a
very serious defensive and much worse
right so we can see that you know even a
great player like the TF you know
unfortunately miss played a position and
sometimes you know can help following
general principles like being flexible
can make a big difference in your own
chess game I really wonder what I see
for wasn't played because this looks
like after takes one c5 the d4 square
it's gonna be really important for white
and it I feel like black would maybe
still even be better after something
like c4
I'm not sure if he'll be better because
of course the C file would be closed
then it will be much harder for
you know after move like 93 I think it's
anyone's games though right
but of course I feel like yeah I feel
like after queen is six from ba do you
see why she's getting everything is
getting a porn plus activity understand
and yeah it's a pity because well I mean
maybe it's a great chance for Aaron
Jacobson I mean Brandon Jacobson to make
a comeback because he still has a chance
to get into him but of course it's a
little bit of a pity for Baraka man that
you have to lose this game where the
opening just went for away but maybe she
will not lose she already had a tough
position against Castro which she came
back from salutely still anyone's game
and Dolson of note Aaron only has three
minutes left
I mean Brandon only has not even a spot
they always confused the brothers and
nice that they both got to play here but
it is a little hard on us
so yeah with with all that I should I
should know though I've played them both
they're New Jersey and I've played them
both tons of times only but you know
somehow so let's actually take a look at
some of the pairings we have for this
round actually so as you saw top ten bob
raha me on is playing Brandon Jacobson
and seem to have an advantage but maybe
it's slipping through the cracks now and
then we also have Casa Corley playing
Andrew Hong Justin Wang playing jacks
tabouli AK and JJ playing Brian
Escalante and Dennis Burroughs playing
joel of Vanuatu is the leader of that
round-robin actually right now so
that'll be an important game to keep an
eye on yeah so let's maybe take a look
at that game now let's see how joel is
faring a game yeah so important of note
Joel yesterday was playing Brandon and I
was following that game live and I think
Joel had a good position out of the
opening was out playing him but then you
know in the position which was still
full of fight it looks like he offered
or took a draw and I know that in my
experience whenever you take a drop in a
position where you could still fight
very often that ends up backfiring and
we can see that in this game black is
kind of struggling right I mean that's
happened many times to me in tournaments
where like I've taken a draw in a
position I could still fight yeah and
then I would end up losing this game so
let's hope this will not happen too so
Joel but I mean I was actually talking
about it yesterday how it's important if
really wanna you know get the GM Norman
over perform your rating but like 150
200 points you gotta take advantage of
your opportunities because sometimes you
know there's gonna be some games that go
your way and you gotta take advantage of
them because there's gonna be always one
or two games which will not go your way
yeah and these good players and in this
game it looks like somehow the opening
went kind of well for white it's a very
ambitious exchange French from Danish
bores with the opposite side counseling
and not sure if black chose necessarily
the best plan but certainly he's playing
very logical he's trying to attack so
let's see what happened here
yeah maybe Queen c7 wasn't maybe night
before was was better but of course it's
hard to so say for sure yeah night
before trying to just either trade or
get rid of that Bishop but Queen c7 was
played King b1 defending a threat and
now White has this threat push takes of
six right so black played here Queen e2
but this whole thing didn't really do
much unfortunately black can't even
continue with rook e8 because of
suddenly this very nice mate right here
yes so that means that black has to play
an awkward move like g5 or a passive
home like Queen d8 so black went for
very concrete play but it didn't really
help blacks position very much so black
ended up going g5 and white played
Bishop g3 maybe even better was a very
unconventional move g3 Oh
you know meeting Bishop d6 with this
amazing night 65 yeah
but mister g3 is also very promising for
white and queen of one a very nice solid
move getting out of the pin preparing
some 95 so let's see what happened here
h4 o p8 rook takes a true take see it hg
maybe it was worth keeping the bishop
Bishop a5 or Bishop e2 but he traded it
at least you know that kind of
alleviated some pressure and maybe
Russia won wasn't the best maybe Queen
h3 was a little better is certainly this
watering me forcing this and they may be
some Knight a for but he decided to play
for Russia
you know creating a not subtle pin not
subtle threat mistakes of four but now
Knight h5 was a good find by black and
it turns out black kind of keeps his
positions together because after this
who enough for rope here amazingly
enough there's king of fate and there's
a mate threat with rook e1 here so
there's not much white is not winning so
I decided to go for the poor but this is
only an extra point in the net game
which of course could still I mean and
also not I don't think Bishop e5 was the
best move maybe loses a tempo black
probably wants to play off six anyway
right yeah and you know now we've got an
endgame where you know it's it's one of
these it's a double poor extra pawn but
a double poor and maybe black has fair
drawn chances and let's see there's been
a couple of more moves made roachie one
CD and f4 so pretty sharp still pretty
sharp interesting stuff it's definitely
a game to keep an eye on white maybe
giving the the pawn back here right
after well thing like if you taste
though yeah he could take and then white
wants to take well the reason he did not
take right away was because that'll
actually lose king of six you think you
can defend everything with a four right
but then black comes with a nasty shot
look takes d5 removal of the guard and
black is winning that's where fours a
very important move but now it's you
know even after this deed 63 it's not so
easy because root x g5 king of six still
and there's no you know immediate win
and it's still anyone's game
it's those whites pressing but anything
could still happen absolutely
so with all that going on in the GM
section we do also have the IM round
robin so how about we take a look at our
current standings there and then maybe
you have a look at the pairings let's
see what players are up to so leading
the field we have a four-way tie for
first with gory as our chambers Aaron
Jacobson and tauros tauros tauros s and
behind them with one and a half points
are Keaton Kiera Eric Rosen and Rochelle
woo the fields youngest player
and also I think the the lowest rate of
player making a good showing of it
scoring 50% in these first three rounds
and rounding out the field Kenta
she karate' peter Geonosis and Erin
Griffin ski and so let's have a look at
the pairings maybe yeah so let's take a
look at the Rachelle's game because the
resist game is good is whining so yeah
we're gonna look at the pairings and
then we'll jump into the jump into that
I can so we've got Keaton Cara playing
in Serie shell whoo Erin Griffin ski
playing in peter giotto's ezra chambers
playing Eric Rosen which I believe that
game has finished yes everybody want the
bear yeah Louise stories against Kent a
shoe karate and also Peter won against
Erin ah yes finish that as well and then
we have Gauri playing against Aaron
Jacobson and with that in mind our key
matchup for this round is Aaron Jacobsen
playing against Gauri Shankar okay but
before we go to that game chefs just
quickly see what happened here basically
keeping Kiara is about to win against
Rochelle woo it was like a slow jump off
tsuki game and it was a slow type of
game and you know it's pretty natural
for a more experienced in international
master to try to play a slower game
against a younger player and right it
looks like black was holding on pretty
fine but eventually a white was able to
outplay I mean at some point looks like
here maybe again the same 9075 is
controlling the a5 score pretty nicely
white has to move to e7 it's not clear
and that's kind of where black lost the
thread white got some Queen side
initiative and this is where kind of
blacks down full started and you know
and then I yeah and as you could see you
know white you know and actually bla I
already officially won because basically
there's just no way of stopping queening
work either one of the points they just
got to none game Bishop on a1 just nice
to control the squares so let's go
without said let's go to God Shankar
scheme yeah thank you
I guess Aaron both of these players I
think are on two out of three and so
they're both tied for first so
definitely gonna be a key match for the
standings yeah so I know that for guy
you're in it really needs this win
because he had
she karate yester on the ropes but you
know let that game slip to a draw and
then he had a quick draw at the next
game against Eric right so he really
felt like he needed the rest and
recharge his batteries to try to play a
good game here and came to play today
and it he'd really did come to play
because she played a very sharp line
here with night BD 2 which is actually a
pawn sack and black took on the
challenge accepted the pawn and played
this 595 Knight is met with 95 so this
is flying castles there should be seven
and here I'm not I might be wrong but I
think there is a move like this and then
some Queen f4 Wow followed by maybe
Bishop takes d5 I mean there are some
sharp lines here or maybe you can also
start with a four yeah I believe it's
supposed to be okay for white but white
but Queen c2 here and already after this
should be seven it looks like White's
running out of compensation right a3 a5
b 3 maybe 4 was a bit better but B 3 C 3
and yeah that ponen C 3 punches landed
there it's very strong points so I don't
really believe in White's position here
so it may be Eve or was necessary
B through me to premature since the c3
probably probably force should be played
and then somehow b3 and even even the
spawn and those hanging there should be
2 and B 64 some development why it still
has very good compensation but yeah this
is this seems like the wrong plan and
now black looks like just up a pawn
knight c6 trading off the active knight
on d5 right takes takes e4 Knight f6
Bishop g5 castles rooty rooty 127 d5
this show takes King takes Queen takes
e5 I'm sure blacks all that in advance
yeah in all the curse takes takes takes
takes takes takes so black is actually
completely winning here well yeah when
you for quit and now though black made a
mistake he played rock f8 which gives up
such an important pawn which pretty much
holds the spawn together after which he
loses almost all his advantage
what black should have done is a move
like Queen f5 because if you hold on to
the spawn you basically won the battle
on the Queen side as long as you
neutralize blacks attack ok game is over
so probably he was afraid of queen chief
or I'd be when some moves like Queen a4
with idea of Queen h4 right but then
black still could defend very easily
with a move like Queen c5 and the Queen
can always come to f8 ok so there is
never gonna be any checkmating ideas and
as long as there's no checkmate this
pawn will eventually win the game
so black you know missed a very big
opportunity here by kind of playing Rock
f8 which basically gives up the lines
share of the advantage because now white
gets back both thorns and now you'll end
up having some 4 and 3 endgame which is
probably gonna be drawn so this is what
happened
black decided to play safe but of course
now his winning chances have really
taken a very big hit and now White has
excellent run chances because also the
pawn and c6 needs to be babysat right
it's very hard for black to generate
very much there was been a couple or
more moves made h6 or of d2 Quinn a 5 of
course black is still the one playing
for a win right but white is expecting a
draw at this point right most likely yes
so and now I think we're actually going
to bring in Eric Rosen and have a look
at his nice win today yeah let's take a
look at that game together huh yeah so
let's see what happened in this game so
is Bishop it was a real Lopez there's a
closed through Lopez it should be three
ships e5 Knight c3 h6 95 G 63 rugby 8
castles castles h3 takes IDI 97 d4 Edie
Knight takes Bishop e7 yeah possibly
you know rook e8 was also an idea to
keep the bishop flexible but okay there
should be 792 not quite sure about the
move 92 looks like defensive move and
now it looks like blocks already taking
over the initiative here
Queen g3 Bishop takes d5 very nice
tactic based on the idea after this rook
takes it to and from this point on it
looks like black one a relatively smooth
game so with that said we have Eric
Rosen with us in the studio today Eric
how do you feel about this game I feel
good good to be back I think last time I
was here I was interviewing you yeah I
know I gave it this far yeah I think
that's pretty cool yeah so I finally
have respect for what it means to be a
player and I finally have respected what
it has to give take interviews as well
because sure it's a little I'm also it's
new for me but even so you know we'll
see what happens I'm not sure which is
more tiring like being a commentator or
being a player well the thing is I've
been used to being a player and giving
interviews for so for me it's already
like very second nature but taking
interviews was something I'm still kind
of mentally getting yeah but I'm sure
it'll be it'll be fine come on
two questions yes so what do you think
was the main career were the main
critical moments in this game yeah I
mean starting with the opening I wasn't
sure what to expect I think I mean he's
capable of playing a lot of things and I
did some broad kind of opening
preparation mm-hmm but he played sort of
a mainline Spanish I think the first
move he surprised me with this is early
d3 early d3 so you were expecting
castles right yes yeah and councils of
course the more of a mainline and the
game can branch out into like so many
different ways yeah there's 964 lines
maybe he was afraid of some yeah he told
me like after the game he didn't want to
deal with like open variation right open
he wasn't sure what to expect for me
either yeah so he decided to play a more
solid line with d3 which is a viable
line b3 Bishop c5 and this is a line
that I've played before but I haven't
really studied recently I know it's
tricky like though the move order he
plays with like Knight c3 and an early
95 block has to be very careful for
example I think in this position the
move order is very important like if I
Castle first
instead of d6 instead of D sick
so some chief or there's there's some g4
idea I forget when but maybe not here
but if some giri yeah maybe like rook g1
first or I received may be taking on f6
Bishop d5 then she won all maybe here
could be action well then maybe 94 but
maybe [ __ ] 25 first I know it at some
point like it can get very dangerous
right yeah yeah so I mean the thing is
the move d6 you probably need to play
anyway right you're not gonna be able to
go d5 so it makes sense to just play it
and see what he does yes c3 rugby 8 yeah
I feel like the game was relatively
level we were both taking yeah this is
all really pretty normal um and I mean
this the critical moment I think was
Knight takes d5 because it really
determines the structure yes and yeah I
was having a hard time evaluating this
position because when I played my takes
d5 I'm planning to go Bishop to d7 so it
takes takes instead of instead of Knight
65 oh no so after so when I play Knight
takes d5 I calculated all the way until
Bishop d7 what happened Wow okay god yes
so it takes takes in Bishop e7 mm-hmm
and it seems a little counterintuitive
because my Kings side looks kind of
vulnerable gets Queen d4 or Queen h5
ideas and then also like Bishop c2 and
my King can come under fire but I I
thought I had enough defensive resources
like Knight g6 and Queen f6 fluency 8
maybe even the earth Queen Chi 3 there
are some takes takes that's true too yes
so it seemed like there are a few
options for glad yeah it looks like
block is fine I was wondering if you
considered an alternative here ruby
force wait to make a decision yeah no
this makes a lot of sense yeah I mean
trying to disturb his harmony so anyway
he played 92 that doesn't seem like the
most interesting move right yeah I think
around this points next several moves
for white we're a bit passive and yeah
now you have the initiative yeah there's
some very nice flow like I remove I play
improves and brings another piece to
attack yeah Queen x4 b3 or op8 yeah it's
all very natural I play rugby Yates it
comes with a threat which I think you
just missed right yeah yeah after
spreading Bishop takes d5 yeah I'm not
sure how why this
to deal with it not so easy maybe maybe
before this should be three but of
course that's a little bit ugly yeah it
is yeah so yeah it looks like a white
kind of played to defensively and now
you even were able to she was crumbled
very quickly because my all my pieces
are coordinated and I like the smooth
bishop c6
with the idea of playing rook D 555 yes
and there's an interesting line here if
he plays rook e1 either a key one I just
trained so takes takes takes thanks and
then in the very end I have bishop takes
it so yes this bishop is no longer
covering up for right yeah so so dope d5
Queen f3 95 at this point I think it was
just a matter of simplifying yeah
although technically you could get away
with rook takes T to apparently but you
know if when you could play move like
Knight g4 it's simpler cuz here 62
there's nine five at some points well
it's nine five here I think you go
Knight g4 and this is a mate because
King G one Queen h3 wanna spin what if
King do you want to be Kings you want
the stakes of - okay yeah and if he and
if he starts with this we need to change
King yeah I didn't want to calculate all
these right yeah yeah yeah even here you
end up with two pieces for represent
it's true but of course you know when
you see a move that wins in a simple way
then there is no reason to you know
complicate calculate something because
you could miss a detail and then you can
you know yes this is relatively simple
there is one final trick in after rook a
- I wanted to take with the bishop on f2
but then he has Bishop h7 check right
exactly yeah be careful of simple
tactics yeah always look at opponent's
ideas and you know hear those nice
finish the night gets trapped and well
it does get out but now it's just two
extra bones with compensation basically
they're two bishops and more active so
various so very nice game today
nice job so I do want to ask you a
question about the game number two I
know that that game you know it was a
very interesting fighting game when
where Rafael played very well and she
came very close
to to winning at what moment you thought
that you know you had you starts having
real drawing chances and you started
getting optimistic that you can save the
game I mean first of all I want to just
say one thing about Rochelle I mean
she's developed a lot over the years I
played her at like this national event
in Atlanta maybe three four years ago so
she was like maybe nine or ten at the
time and we were just playing blitz but
she found some like very strong ideas in
our game actually I've been doing game
recaps every day on on my own twitch
channel I'll post it on YouTube
afterwards right I go through my
thoughts extensively but I wasn't
comfortable in that game at least when I
was on the defensive I mean at some
point it was completely winning for
whites but I wasn't comfortable until
the very end when the pawn gets to 287
and then they have this stalemate Rick
but I was wondering I mean there were a
couple of times when you earlier in the
game you could have tried to change the
Queen's was the reason you didn't want a
shape change the Queen's because
potentially it would have given her
drawing chances was it still that you
were trying to play for a widow I was
trying to play for a win because I I was
up maybe 20 minutes on the clock
and she had I mean she got down to two
minutes like pretty early so I think
psychologically I have over over pushed
and then then it backfired and then I
had to hold on yeah but does it look
like you know to me it looked like it
seems at first of her King was the one
that was weak but the night and did to
kind of covered everything and then your
King action in long run becomes weaker
because yeah you know she played
incredibly well on your tongue I'm not
sure I mean she found like she
neutralized all my threats and then
found counterplay at this g5 was very
strong but then when she was on like the
verge of winning
she let me simplify into this this
ending which was a little bit tricky
yeah the end game though I already
realized once you got onto that end game
a and H points I knew that there's a
good chance you would draw that because
it's it's very so easy
but were you familiar with the Vancouver
positions and things like so yeah I
actually do know the van Cora position I
this
who I've had multiple lessons like just
on the van chorus we've played it out
for both sides and I guess that's one
benefit to teaching chess and then my
students motivate me to learn these
these theoretical positions but
thankfully we didn't even have to get to
that yeah yeah Sheamus plated yeah but I
mean this is this is why to all of you
listening this is why it's very useful
to know theoretical end games because
when you know some basic theoretical end
games you know let's say when you're
defending which kind of end games to go
to and how to defend so I strongly
recommend to all of you to check out
Eric Rosen's YouTube recaps rich in
YouTube you switch Enrica because I'm
sure you'll learn a lot from from that
game because it was a very interesting
fighting game and just the way Eric came
back shows a lot of grit in the game and
you know and now you know we see that
when you fight off the tough game
sometimes good things happen to you
later
you know well I do want to say like
after that game I was just so so drained
of energy it was a last game to finish
around - and I think we finished maybe
around 3:30 so I had 90 minutes to to
eat rest and prepare for the next game
and then going into next game I I wanted
to fight
I laid the London opening like trying to
to get some preparation the gauri
neutralized like very quickly he played
one one line which I'm not so fond of
from the white side and then then he
offered me a draw and I think it made
sense to take it and just write and
recharge and you know focus on the rest
of the tournament and get your energy
back so the two game of days schedule is
brutal like if if I had the the game
against Rochelle four and half hours and
then have another four and a half hour
fights I mean it's it's so exhausting so
yeah and that's despite the fact that I
know you've written some articles I
think about good physical shape so
you're a thinker you're one of the more
fit players in that field that said I
mean and I think that's what helped you
grind through that your shell game in
some ways physical so everybody who's
listening
fiddles physical fitness is very
important and I remember Eric Rose Eric
has written some very nice articles on
us as our org think about about that
themes also Chris
in korilla as like a whole article one
of the top articles because there
anywhere we could they can see a link
like that's a good question you have to
google us chests org then either my name
or kristen carosa frozen or slash
Christian Sharia and then if you really
want to you should be able to find it so
Eric thanks a lot for coming I wanted to
point out something yes I was watching
the broadcast right before I came on and
I think it's a card shankar jacobson
game yes I guess so let's city sure
there's a line that you didn't mention
it was a beautiful moment when black
gave away the the b-pawn remember this
yes it was
so Queen takes before yeah Queen but I
have a feeling that he he saw Queen
takes before
yes but he didn't see after see - aha Oh
to move in this position maybe we can
let the YouTube chat oh you get out oh
good point the I didn't oh yeah that's
it
wait doesn't have the next move then oh
yeah your rock is winning good point
yeah that's that's a very good point
actually you're absolutely right yeah
maybe this was what was Miss Lee bye-bye
Brandon I mean by Erin yeah it's such an
unusual idea and like you need the pawn
enough six to actually make it work yeah
so we can show it now right yeah I mean
if people want to think like just pause
the video yeah what Queen takes f8
double exclam king takes and rook t 8
and an opponent of six does an
incredible job
mating yes so that's why it's important
when we're playing chess to calculate at
least a few moves ahead you can't just
say okay Queen before c2 and stop the
variation you gotta continue analyzing
if you really want to become best
wrestler and unfortunately this was
costly as a result at least what the
good thing Brandon did is he I mean
Aaron did was he didn't blitz out c2
assuming at least he double check the
lion yeah that would be tragic yeah
so if you still have you know winning
chances in this game but of course as we
could see this was how what happened and
soon we're gonna have room to XT to
probably Quincy 8 4 & 3 & 4 & 3 as we
all know very good drawing chances and
could be a long game it will probably be
a very long game I'm sure black will try
for a long time but of course probably
Gauri is very happy to get out of this
with something like this right thanks a
lot for mentioning death yeah for sure
well I'm gonna get some food and
recharge and prepare so let's that's the
luck to you in the rest of the
tournament I wish you very nice fighting
games appreciate it thanks thanks for
coming
yes so now we're gonna continue looking
at see what happened with Brandon
against that chef
so we last we left you off with this
position I believe after rugby ADC night
63 at 63
Queen takes e5 and in this position a BB
five was a slightly better chance but
963 and 63 Queen c5 was played King D -
maybe queen a7 was bit better still a
complicated position so King did sue 9f
594 even here black should have tried to
activate that rook somehow and trade of
those rooks you know trade off his
inactive piece for why it's active and
it's still not all that clear night of
five was played now white had actually a
very interesting possibility of taking
taking Queen a7 and then followed by
Queen takes g7 with a very big attack
but of course it's very hard to see that
on time pressure so white played natural
move 94 and even still rook f8 probably
should have been played but rook c8
Queen g3 King g7 rugby 5 Queen c7 Knight
takes c6 Queen takes here rook takes B
696 Russia for and actually even here
black got chances because for example
here rook takes a 5 again was quite
crushing but 9625 and here this was
quite strong and then let's say move
like rook takes d5 or maybe even c4
better move but it's pretty complicated
so white did this and here actually
amazingly enough black is back in the
game after moves like g5 shutting down
the G file or move like 94 but
unfortunately black took here and this
ends up being losing because after this
King c1 the attack just ends up being
too strong Queenie 7 Queen takes Queen
a6 Ruki 8 and then there's been a couple
of more moves made rookie six Queen f7
Queen a3 that's precise
and Queen a8 and I think white is
repeating move spots actually white is
completely winning the race if they can
gonna fake can't really survive yeah
yeah with that in mind I think maybe one
or two games are actually wrapping up
here Oh actually there's a yeah there's
a breaking news
Dennis borders did end up beating Joel
bond over in this game so CD was
happening as we expected a for king of
six but now instead of king of six maybe
this deserved attention so King of six
was played and now white went for a very
interesting line takes and here it was
actually possible to do this White's
idea of course was to give a check then
then maybe 93 and I'm not sure if this
end game is actually winning for do you
play C takes D and then take tonight you
can do CD but then let's say king of
four rocked XC three Ruby g8 and there's
still some may be drawn chances here I
don't know last rookie five and
amazingly maybe this King and ponen game
is not losing God say here king c2 king
of four and then king e4 but of course
it's very hard to see that so King g7 is
natural a4 but now white was able to
stabilize that Knight takes takes 96
King C to rotate shade rooty one and
yeah it looks like now well there was
one shrub it cannot take because of my
III Chris but rugby one rotates to King
g3 rotates three kings ooh and now
Knight g4 nice reposition of the night
night hereand probably was better to
just try to get counter blue with g4
sure it looks I mean this my eyes it
looks kind of hopeless at this place
yeah he just repeated move but now she's
six is coming and there's gonna be made
threatened that's all she wrote so with
that said that's that's huge for the
standings right because Joel was
actually leading the field by half point
yeah I think and by the way some
breaking stuff happen in this game
because I
we said in a white who's totally winning
but here white went for this line which
was not actually the winning line white
should have played c4 undermine this
porn and threatening root X t4 and
there's nothing actually black and do
black still stuck in the pinion even
giving this checkers useless because
just king b2 so there's actually no way
black can really stop the attack sure
so yeah why didn't white what did I go
for and said I'm sorry give a check Tok
Tok and went for Queen text e5 but this
actually is still a chance for for block
after move like 95 it's still not so
clear amazingly enough
95 doesn't I Queen a 5 and then Queenie
five Queen a five-night of 7 9 f 7 okay
yeah depending on this blocking the f5
yeah just well because right now black
has to do something with white
threatening Queen of 5 so black
absolutely has to defend against this
trend followed by Queen text C 4 so it's
still a very dangerous position but the
TF found 95 so she's actually completely
back in the game she's actually maybe
amazingly not worse again so this is
really a very back and forth game with a
lot of swings like an incredible fight
it's just it's a I guess in lieu of puns
black it's just guarding is came with
the the pieces directly a completely
incredible game yet putting bodies in
the way yeah okay yeah so amazing stuff
so which game should we go to next week
check out Jack's key maybe guns just in
the Wang and see if I know that this was
a very complex French game with a lot of
back-and-forth games and now it looks
like it's heading towards some kind of a
draw because I'm very lucky it's very
hard for either side truly breakthrough
I'm not even sure who's playing for a
win here so we'll kind of leave that
game aside for now and let's check and
see if anything happened in the Chi
Kurata
ah that was actually a very big update
because tourists Luis Carlos one just
now against she karate as you could see
why it's about the Queen the poor and
once again it looks like the opening
went a bit tough for black and if we've
noticed you know black has Chico Radha
has had some trouble but would good luck
you know getting worse position so I
guess that's something to to think about
threesome opening mistakes yeah and
future tournaments because he's a very
sharp player playing very ambitious
openings right but of course when you
play sharp that would block you couldn't
get bad positions and you could get out
plates so this is what happened well you
analyze this game a little bit I'm
actually gonna about I think we're gonna
have Dennis burrows and perfect an
interview to go over that game that he
just perfect so let's let me go back to
the TF game because that's really a you
know game that can go either way it's a
very dramatic game and now we see
Brandon is going down so those last
seconds desperately looking for a way to
continue playing and he came up with a
move Queen c5 giving a check seeing what
black does so now black has a few ways
to deal the check he can go Queen e7 or
he can go king of seven he goes king of
seven actually that would be a losing
mistake because after Queen of five
check King g7 Queenie five check there
is no way to defend against the mating
attack but the TF played the correct
move more natural move he she played
Queen d7 so Queen e7 was played and this
position should still be a draw so
couple of my moves were played Queen c8
Queen e8 and I'm wondering if you know
Brandon will just you know make a
perpetual or repeat moves or whether
he'll actually try to play for a win but
will let them fight it out in the
meantime we have a guest here Dennis
boorish and let's check out his game
against the Joba novel which we just
took a look at so
Dennis thanks a lot for coming yeah
thank you for having me yeah so how do
you feel about this game what did you
think were the main critical moments in
this game so I think well in the
beginning there were many critical
moments because I played kind of a bear
new system mm-hmm that yeah and the new
system as yeah as I was saying in the
live concerts exchange French what would
in a very ambitious way with the
opposite side counseling it's actually
funny because if you play the French and
you do you know that white is basically
playing the reversed French attack yeah
so if you can go back a little bit yes
and let's say II takes d5 instead of
Knight c3 yeah oh you oh I see what
you're saying yeah thanks
he takes Knight f3 knight c6 mmm this
should be five Bishop g4 right Castle
Queen d7 and voila it's the reversed
okay yeah of course yeah but of course
here doesn't quite work because there's
Queen 195 but exactly Apatow well you
can play that right that makes sense
should be six here yeah you have to plan
your sub D six or something in a more
subtle but yes that's a good point
and in fact Simon Williams shout out to
him he recommended this system I think
in his shows love convey Dios
so with blacks so yeah but would of
course if you're white you know you're
up a tempo this kind of thing works
pretty well and I'm not sure what does
the more most critical move here
actually maybe it's you know not playing
c6 right away but in any event was this
still your prep work yes
c6 rookie one was still prepped but a5
was interesting and and in fact I was
wondering if he wants to go Knight a
six-night c7 96 because I think if the
night lands on the e6 there's nothing I
remember that I had a game which was
very similar to that in the in this kind
of similar tournament here again starter
switch yeah and this in the Fall Classic
and I also try to do this plan but there
he played more salt
he played with Bishop d3 of 392 he ended
up casting short once I committed on
this plan and I actually ended up
getting a bad position because once you
play a 596 it's very hard to play c5
yeah and it's hard to take advantage of
the f3 move yeah and I learned a lot
from playing the game I amazingly I
saved a draw but I was completely losing
in a game I was completely outplayed you
can also check out that game that I was
black against terriers but here
a little bit different story because
it's an opposite side castling we played
Bishop d6 which either a very good move
I think he has to go Bishop e6 and
that's critical hmm I'm not even sure I
can go Knight f3 ego 95 yeah and look at
just a fighting position yes I'm not
sure if white is better I think it's
just a game
yeah it's yeah it's certainly a very
sharp position to analyze but Bishop d6
might still be okay but I'm not sure
about age 6 what was your plan if he
would have played the simple night do
you think still 95 still 95 95 95 and
then big screen d3 and I mean you still
have issues with your Bishop and c8 and
my time is very easy I go h4g for f4 yes
time for that but probably equal
position but maybe easier for whites a
place especially if you're familiar with
it yes so h6 Bishop h4 and now he played
for a very concrete plan but it just
doesn't seem to work I think he should
have still played 19 for 4 and traded
off his night that's offside yeah but
instead he went for this you know tricky
idea meeting this for this of course but
of course after a simple King b1 and
this before probably also not best it
turns out that it's very hard to deal
with this threat at night of mistakes of
6 in a comfortable way yeah it's I mean
I've seen this from the suffering side
it's very hard to do anything because
it's a closed position and blackness
plays all of his pieces yeah shockingly
there's nothing yeah and after this you
know by the way did you consider this
interesting yes yes yes when he played
g5 I said oh wait what if I do g3 but
Felder Bishop d6 Knight takes H takes
Bishop takes g5 and I don't see a reason
why to go for this variation
and like I thought that I'm comfortable
why risk this I wasn't sure but I saw
this g3 idea I don't know is it working
it's completely winning meaning yeah
it's over more than plus two oh so I
guess nine eight seven takes screen age
five I h7 products mate right yeah it's
making Queen it's my yeah so I think he
has to play some Queen d8 but then huh
Queen f3 I just it seems kind of hard to
defend here King g7 just h4 h5 rookie
fives oh yeah oh maybe it's not so easy
to see all the subtleties but basically
it is completely winning but yeah I mean
it was certainly a very interesting
possibility but of course you're right
if you don't see it all till then then
it makes sense to play Bishop g3 because
it's simpler and I'm not sure about
Queen f1 I was probably pretty good yeah
I thought it's very ambitious because I
saw clean e7 I think is awesome
advantage yeah when you're seven is
nothing else so much better yeah so
Queen f1 and I think he should never
take on f3 because I what else know that
95 those cops yeah that's true 95 is
coming but I think P sure I don't know
no I think actually he's me rec you play
kind of resilient Lea but maybe h4 maybe
you can play five Bishop a5 from an h4
because actually he got at some point
real drunk chance Yeah right
it's gee thanks takes it takes and then
maybe
quinna five here and maybe when you take
immediately yes
or maybe Quidditch three or maybe take
immediate you need three King f8 I'm not
sure if I'm I have anything some night a
409 a 400 kind of subtle subtle Knight
b6 yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure if it
really it's I mean it's maybe not a four
right away also but you know it's an
idea for this very computer like yeah
yeah that's true I would never think of
it yeah yeah because the knight on c3 is
not doing well but we're probably right
that I should have played Bishop f5
earlier yes and here yeah my King is a
little bit yeah here actually if he goes
96 what would you do here I
thought I have there should be six here
Misha b6y announce a king f7 and then
yeah rook is just coming and now your
Bishop is kind of odd yeah so actually I
think Black was close to being
completely fine but of course it's still
you have the practical advantage and
eventually you're able to grind the win
out you know you played think a very
nice technical game you know f4 was of
course yes yeah also as a must
oh yeah yeah because I showed already in
the yeah like I'm I could even lose
quickly if I fall for some tricks yeah
g5 king at sea yeah exactly I was sort I
was shown that in the in the rookie 5
yeah that's very painful especially
after a good position yeah yeah yeah
yeah but yeah this was nice yes it takes
g5 I was very happy when I saw if thanks
g5 I know that everything should be
under control now yeah you're always you
know never losing chances and always
much better and from this point on I
think you played quite well I mean there
may be subtle tease but you know your
technique from here was excellent and of
course here he lose lost to tempest but
yeah but it was already going downhill
so excellent game Dennis so that brings
you to what's your score now I think
plus 2 plus 2 very good so you know
hopefully a chance to you know really do
some damage and and show these you know
guys who are trying to get norms still
you know kind of there's something left
to learn something we need to learn yes
yeah but yeah and I was pretty amazed
with Justin's game yesterday he beat
Cara Corley yeah is positional game like
it almost seems flawless yeah it was
very nice he is sorted life I kind of
felt that there deserves I mentioned
what's your opinion about currently this
position ah well actually it changed a
white is now completely winning the
earth Queen b8 and yeah 6 of 7
you just said that well
Jacobson take a draw I think he never
takes the draw and risky positions yeah
I don't see I didn't I didn't think it's
very realistic so he ended up playing
here night of seven rookie six Queen g7
Quincy five King g7 what happened here
rookie seven and here rook c8 was such a
chance to come all the way back so Luke
see it is quite strong yeah but I'm
wondering if there any other moves
besides that but yet maybe not maybe not
yeah but yeah this is and I guess this
is the current position so I'm wondering
if you will find some I guess you'll
just take on f7 and Queen h8 no good
yeah yeah yeah did that and it's just I
mean well yeah I mean well actually I
think you know you missed a very big
chance here but Queen f6
and then actually black is in some zoo
Swank which is support you're just
pushing the phone yeah there's nothing -
amazing amazing game but instead this
was played and and now we have this
position on the board with white having
all the winning chances but it still
might not be so easy to wait what should
be probably closer to win then draw
although although the king is quite
close and the H pawn starts running so
it's kind of a closest oh I mean what
should be winning yeah so amazing
dramatic game and yeah once again I'll
let you arrest before your next game now
and thanks a lot for coming here thank
you alright so this game is now in an
endgame stage so we're gonna start
looking at some other games just to kind
of see what's been happening and wow
this game you know for a long time I
kind of wrote it off as some kind of
maybe a draw but then something
incredible happened he you know Jack
decided to just sacrifice a piece here
for a pawn I don't understand this at
all like what is what is he trying to do
here how I mean he is probably trying to
play for a win but now he'll probably
will
losing and we're exactly even is his
winning chances so it seems like a very
decision here this is this game is over
let's see what happened in the car Yuri
game against Jacobson has there have
been any special events they appear for
v3 and it's just pure for v3 and this is
also gonna be an end game that's gonna
be a grind for obviously a very very
long time so let's see what else this
game we looked at this game we also
looked at and then there's you know this
game can take a while so let's go back
to oh we did never really got a chance
to look at Andrew Hong's game El Paso
poorly and unfortunate Corley's news
troubles continue yeah on for and
remember you know he had very nice
positions in the first two games and
unfortunately if you start off badly in
a tournament like this you miss chances
your moods not the same and you're just
doubting yourself and it just somehow
happened I mean can he have to company
how did like for example here he had a
good position out of the opening against
Andrew and you know Andrews sacrifice
the the exchange which probably should
be taken right away and then let's say
Luke g1 but unfortunately for casa
he allowed c5 after which very nice pass
born and now he took but now the
Pawlenty force significant is stronger
much better construction and even here
it looks like you know blacks position
was easier to play and and though just
kind of lost the threat here and like
won a nice game from here on push the
porn and defended all his weaknesses it
makes it look easy just simply putting
the pawn on t2 and then using the night
yeah there's a very nice recovery for
Andrew after his soft loss yesterday
against the TF in a back-and-forth game
so let's take a look again at Brandon's
game let's see if anything major
happened
so we were left off for it somewhere
here as we said you know here white was
completely winning but again with so
little time it's very hard to play very
precise so now we have an end game where
White has excellent winning chances but
of course black is not without drunk
chances because as we know in Queen Anne
games there are a lot of Perpetual chat
ideas right and you always have to
calculate a lot so let's see if Brandon
will be able to sew right through the
win here yeah and in the same game is
what if black simply tries to just push
the H pawn I thought yeah probably is
something like Queen h5 and then white
will hope to push this porn across or
this one before black sure somehow be
able to coordinate the Queen and the
pawns and the way to kind of keep blacks
counterplay Bay and you know get its own
counter play going but of course this is
gonna be still a very long road ahead
for right for Brandon and in the Jax
game nothing really much happened he
just took the piece and I don't know
what is it says zero zero zero but
there's no result I'm wondering if black
Ashley lost on time or maybe yeah it's
it's possible the game still going these
clocks aren't always accurate to the
second so yeah but I mean there's not
there haven't been any moves made yet so
I'm a little unsure I think actually
that might be the position on the camera
there so we can actually see a jack
still considering his move
oh yeah that's that's true yeah this is
junk right yeah yes they're still
playing and but somehow it's not
updating us and what is this game this
is yeah this is just okay so let's check
from diary this game and see if anything
fritz pretty much still kind of the same
thing no progress has been made right
yeah it'll be there a while but yeah
this is a position with a jack actually
looks pretty interesting right well yes
except for we don't see any many moves
here so right yeah it's pretty hard to
difficult so let's just go back yeah we
can actually just look on the screen
here maybe
see what's going on yeah like they're
just down to pure queen n games oh it's
a black regained it's a queen oh is it
possible that there are some moves that
were incorrectly input it may be that my
ex before never even happened
yeah that's uh that's because that was a
very hard decision too likely
but I mean from what it seems like it
seems like white is actually in trouble
right there's a seep on this well if
I've done the board yeah and I mean
white is hoping for some Queen c6 Queen
counterplay but it looks like it could
be dangerous it looks like black is
although only one who can win here yeah
I don't really believe in Queens e6
actually after just see three kids queen
c6 just be met with King a5 and the King
just comes up the board ah maybe yeah
maybe I mean that's although actually c3
would be a huge blunder here you know
why Queen a a check King b6 and Queen B
a oh goodness
yeah so black has to be very precise
maybe King a5 then King a 5 year and
then there's also an idea like d5
sometimes you know trying to make the e6
blonde pastor right there's still some
dynamics the positions and only a lot of
things to play for but I would still say
black is the one with the winning
chances and we see Sammy shortcut there
leaning in yeah but anyway we cannot
really take a look at that game so we
have to just settle on seeing this game
so as I predicted
h4 was played and then he centralized
the Queen which is oftentimes a very
good idea in Queen and games king of
seven maybe King D 7 was actually better
and now white played c5 so the idea is
simply to push the pawn and if H 2 H 3 H
2 white is kind of faster yeah it looks
like White's making progress here in
this game yeah looking at it here that
the King just the black King can't
really seem to help at all and then the
White Queen nicely defends the diagonal
ins yeah the general rule of thumb is
the Queen and Queen n games the Queen is
very important to be centralized
role in middle games too but especially
in end games like that if the queen is
centralized it usually controls a lot of
very important key squares and that
extra point of White has C to basically
shields the white king yes somehow you
know there's no diagonal check thanks to
the Queen there's no ranked check thanks
to the C pawn and then the Queen really
can't make its way to the B file
right so I would say there's a very good
chance that white will win this game
because it's just very hard to defend
probably yeah I actually I don't see
what blacks doing about just simply see
67 and then queening almost directly
yeah exactly yeah
so this game will probably be a win for
white so TTFN tried h3 but actually now
c6h to c7 you know white will Queen
first and a force of white bull Queens
first in an in an open king position yes
white will just be checkmating so two
queens do work together well so I expect
white to play c6 here and not fear and
ghost and I expect why two in this game
all right
and this game ah now we have the right
position here so let's see what actually
happened here so Oh actually night it
was night before that happened not my
takes d4 interesting that so this piece
sacrifice makes much more sense I think
was after date this at least they're
connected pastors and I'm not sure if
White has to accept that but he did and
actually he actually was able to
generate some winning chances after
Bishop d1 King a5 I mean again maybe a
five queen takes and then Queen f4 was
better but that's very subtle trying to
create counter play with Bishop g7 right
yeah
instead of that Bishop d1 was played now
black could play b3 but played King a5
Queen B to Queen c7 there should be one
Queen b6 I would still say white is not
worse here but should be two Queen a6
King jitsu Quincy 8 there should be one
Queen c6 Queen B 1 Queen b6 Queen B to
King a6 so they're kind of going back
and forth making some increment yeah and
now I decided to sacrifice this which is
a very practical decision now you know
you only have one pass one deal with and
after king f5 we actually have this
position where King f5 was indeed played
and now white played my idea which I was
talking about g5 Edie
because if Queen takes r3 then of course
the pawn on e6 will win
so catched
yes exactly it's so black took and now
the best move might have even been to
play six first but he took this which is
very natural King takes a four and then
he played a six in this position and I
would say in this position it's probably
roughly equal because I think the pawns
are equal is strong but maybe it's even
white who has the practical advantage of
little dangerous dangerous offside
speaking of centralization maybe Queen
c2 here for black and then Queenie for
Queen c2 is probably a good move yeah
Queen c2 and uh but probably you can't
make it to eat for it probably not
quitting because the thing is then e 78
comes with check so if you win at the
same time White Point Queens but check
right but probably blacks should try to
think about trying to make a draw here
with a perpetual and he did that with
Queen B 2 which is also fine and white
but King h3 and now maybe a move like we
D to trying to get closer to the White
King mm-hmm
and we're not really worried about the
f5 point we're just worried about the e6
pawn right and this probably should be a
draw with perfect play and let's go back
quickly to Brandon's game and it looks
like the it's already close to mate here
so h3 c2h2 happened c7 so now
unfortunate for black he asked to move
the Queen out of the way and still one
more chance we actually do have a
handshake that yeah I've because of
first resign then Queen before still
amazingly enough would be a perpetual hi
yeah so wide so has to be careful till
then check and 24 and now this is
completely winning because we covered
the checking square and we Queen and
once they're both Queens on the board
you know White has an easy checkmated
yes so Brandon did end up you know end
up being prevail and hopefully we can
have him in our studio very soon to talk
about a very nice game oh yeah the
meantime we'll give them some time yeah
but in the meantime let's check on this
game and see if there's any updates so
it looks like they've repeated moves a
couple of times and it looks like there
might be you're heading towards the draw
right so going for repetition of moves
so that's stay on this game for a little
bit and see if there anything there
going to be any updates and as always I
do want to mention here
we're kind of in a lull in the action
you know you can watch us on YouTube use
the hashtag norm Congress if you want to
reach out to us we do have the chat up
here it's good to see you guys all
watching and enjoying and yeah hopefully
we can continue to give you guys more of
this you know commentary over these
tournaments we have here and we actually
do have another handshakes and that game
ended up with a draw I assume and yeah
it looks like yes you know they agreed
to draw with a perpetual I mean maybe
white can somehow play on but it's risky
and draw kind of makes a lot of sense
here after a long tough fight and let's
check so this looks like the aaron
jacobson game as last one remained and
looks like still no headway to be made
just the four and three which can still
go on forever ah you know i'm always
curious
so what pun structures are best for the
defending side here usually the form G 3
H 4 yeah that that one is good I think
usually even also the pawn on f4 is also
fine defense of as long as the black
bones not only 5 years great so yeah but
this one is a standard one and basically
if the white pawn is right on h4 it's
gonna be very hard for blacks we got a
winning chance because if you go g4
trying to make progress
you're gonna exchange pawns and the more
pawns you exchange the more closer it
will be to a draw
and speaking of g5 black dude try g5
because you probably was shuffling for a
long time what else can you try to do
but of course this is probably just a
drum hit so kanji 5 king takes and I
move like king Jitsu and you know we
expect this game to you know end in a
draw of course this game can still take
a while but you know certainly draw is
very likely here yeah absolutely
they can't all be you know at a tense
game well this game should have some
interesting moments and as we know that
Brent I mean Aaron probably be kicking
himself a little bit for letting this
one slip away and yeah missing maybe
that nice Queen takes that they attack
yeah yeah yeah it was probably a
combination between overestimating
White's attack there yeah and also
thinking maybe he's winning another line
and you know sometimes that that happens
we misjudge a couple of lines and we go
for the wrong line things can certainly
slip by pretty quickly so um I guess
we'll have to stay at this game for a
while because that's the only game left
yes a white plate Roque eight we're
trying to go to g8 so we actually do
have Brandon Jacobson here ready for an
interview
alright perfect so that's amazing win
against tates
so I can pull that board back up yeah so
let's get back so you know Brandon and I
guess there are a couple of moments that
I will ask him about so once again that
was a French in the line which you know
since there was a such an interesting
game we'll probably start off around
this moment g4 takes takes should be
three a five yes so we'll probably start
off somewhere around here so as we've
discussed here I thought after Knight a5
Bishop e3
I thought Knight c7 was kind of going in
the wrong direction because it kind of
led white get counter-plan the a file
where's Luke f8 would have made much
more sense and after Knight c7 a5 Quincy
six takes takes Queen ace six certainly
white is now getting a lot of play and
even after this black and still play
Roca faith there is certainly a lot of
counter play chances but you know now we
can speak to the man of the hour himself
Brandon Jacobsen Brandon what an
interesting game congratulations on
pulling it out how do you feel now I'm
relieved that it's over but it
definitely wasn't easy
he's probably in trouble at some point
yeah was a very back-and-forth game well
the first moment that I wanted to ask
you about is were you surprised a little
bit that that CF here played Knight c7 I
moved 20 in this position yeah I feel
like I had to somehow show an idea for a
wreck f3 because after a wreckage tree
my original idea was to not play with
Queen d3 I'm playing for Queen age 4 and
a quick chief were mm-hmm and the idea
being after C takes d4 Knight takes d4
mm-hmm something sharp like this but I
wasn't too sure how to evaluate this
mm-hmm so I figured Queen d3 would be
safer mm-hmm right but of course then
black also gets a comfortable game yeah
and that turned out to be maybe a rogue
h3 then wasn't the best idea but here I
thought that blacks should probably try
to play move like Roka fate getting that
last piece in the game yeah and then we
know after a move like Rotex g4 takes
and I mean maybe only if Knight c3 then
you can go Knight c7 but for now we're
not sure where the night belongs but she
made a mistake I think with Knight c7
which gave you a lot of counter blue
with a 5 and even here blocks probably
at some point play c4 maybe even in this
position
c4 wasn't even possible although I still
think that white is already kind of
comfortable
yeah after c4 I figured something like
windy 1 think back and I Chi 3 I'm
getting a lot of counter play here yeah
for sure yeah B and also black lost as
counter play but still it's very salt
for black in any event but of course
that would have been better than than
the game and then here you're definitely
in control yeah the main point is if
instead of Knight takes III d4 I have
Knight takes d4 and the Queen can go
back to f1 right so if Queen h1 queen of
one yes
yeah very important yeah so 963 happened
and f6 e3 Queen 65 and here you put King
D 2 which is of course a very natural
move did you consider this move Queen a7
which is a little bit unusual but as you
can imagine we're both really low on
time
the game was so complicated yeah I
didn't really consider anything besides
yeah it's a very hard to criticize in
time pressure such a complicated
position so King dudes who was played
and now once again but CF should have
activated the rook that wasn't doing
anything
Knight of five was played and here you
had another interesting moment rook
takes and then Queen a7 followed by
followed by this quite incredible
I probably had a few wins even after at
94 94 maybe Roca faith was possible but
rook c8 Queen d3 that's a good move
keeping everything together
King g7 rugby 5 Queen c7 96 very natural
Queen e6 look hereand but amazingly that
night was you know just maybe it was
good to try to get rid of it because
that night turned out to be a very
stubborn piece just always kind of in
the way yeah I just a few seconds here
and oh yeah I was trying to calculate
what takes at five or a 65 I couldn't
find the first win so right yeah I
didn't realize how strong 96 would be
yeah I do six and amazingly after route
84 even here there was rook takes T six
maybe and getting rid of that night
because amazingly after 94 or even g5
it's still anyone's game here but
Queenie six through broke here King here
Ruchi 694 Kings c1 now again you're in
very good shape here but of course it's
still a very complicated position by the
way here a very interesting idea was to
place you for to try to undermine this
and amazing it's one of these where you
don't actually have to force anything
because black is so tied down that
there's not much you can do but you know
after a very sharp game this is still
very unclear amazingly so I was
considering taking a draw here with you
know a few more moves
yeah in this position Oh Queen c5 so
rookie 7 was kind of a risk because we
were both so low on time black actually
has rook c8 here yeah the idea being
Queen e5 look swing but black can go
just go camp
here yeah yeah and I might be in trouble
of losing yeah so you have to go Queen
84 or something like that right but so
you saw I see it yeah but you're
probably not risking that much you're
still probably within drawing range but
of course there's a good chance in such
a position that you know this move might
not be found yeah so that was that was a
good risk it paid off because now you
ended up getting the Queen centralized
and amazingly enough maybe there was a
quicker win with this and then some c4
c5 and Black is again amazingly tied
down it's it's just incredible game like
this game to go over it might take like
three hours or more and still like so
much to learn for even for for me but
it's ultimately you went for a
simplification you know which very good
winning chance sent to them
I think her last chance was probably
King d7 keeping somehow the pawn on c7
at bay maybe like they should be winning
already 25 and then c5 probably it is
winning but maybe that's why the
veterans chance but you know after she
moved the sorry after she moved king f7
then from there on you played very
routinely and I like this Queen e5 a lot
it's just very nice centralization and
the last moment was very nice stopping
the perpetual counter play and you know
you ended up winning so very nice job on
I think you know winning in the end and
how do you feel what's your strategy
going forward I feel like in a lot of
these round-robin tournaments when I
focus too much on the norm
it makes me under confident and then I
spend too much time in my game so I'm
just trying not to think about the
Marmont situation yeah very very very
good advice to to all of us very smart
approach so I'll let you arrest now and
make sure you two take your nap and Eve
and the hopefully you know continue your
great enterprising chests and hopefully
you know more and more games will go
your way and I wish you best of luck
thank you even you're you're the best
result you can get in this tournament
thank you very much
no problem alright so with that said
let's go back to the game that was we're
still going ooh a lot of interesting
things have happened here but it looks
like it's still gonna be a draw so Aaron
is you know desperately looking for a
way to continue the game going but of
course now you know he's we lose in fact
opponent you know at this point well
actually you have to be careful you
cannot take right away because King
Jitsu it's still a little bit of a trap
and actually you end up losing here but
of course you know we don't expect Y to
fall for this trick and take the spawn
although King jutsu is a threat but king
of one actually makes a relatively
straightforward draw but a certain there
was a very nice creative attempt by by
Aaron to try to keep the game going
while we do a wait for this game so I
kind of wrap up do you want to take a
look at maybe the prize funds see what
the players sure are playing sure yeah
let's take a long view
so yeah in the GM section actually it's
pretty interesting they're playing for
$2,000 in first place with the total
prize fund of 9,000 and there are no
losers in st. Louis everybody walks away
with something in sixth through tenth
all get actually $600 for their their
troubles and there are nine rounds of
chess and actually in the IM section
what we have is a prize fund to $6,000
first place being $1,200 and once again
six through 10th all getting $400 so
maybe not the best tournament maybe not
the norm they look hoping for but at
least some some nice change to go home
with yeah so yeah here go URI is
thinking I'm wondering if he he missed
the king g2 idea I mean you think you
should find king of one just because
it's kind of losing though otherwise but
I'm sure he's worrying about let's say
calculating some III rooked xh5 here
rook h4 and here okay there are probably
several ways you can make a draw
the simplest being our Okafor so
takes takes and now a very important of
kingi too and that way you get the
opposition right that's one line that
leads to a very clear draw this is kini
- I guess there's a takes king you -
there's eats except - and king of one
that's the line I was thinking about but
this is also of course leading to a draw
because even though two points I just
remember the wonder game at the you chef
no yes I was thinking yeah there is
there some tricks there but not enough
right not enough yet it's still a draw
so I mean you think you know he should
be able to find king of one because it
looks like actually the only move but it
should be enough to draw all right with
perfect play so you know as I said these
players are playing for an arm and maybe
we can actually take a look at what that
entails in this event so yeah so maybe
we should take a look at GM norm
standings because I think all those are
finished sure
so let's actually read a little bit do
some education here
so to earn a norm you know of course you
have to have a certain performance
rating in this case thanks to the
average rating of our players everybody
in the GM section
who's playing foreigner will actually
need six and a half points to get that
norm and of course we have to play
players from so many different
Federation's and so thankfully we've got
got them all here with JJ representing
turkey Jackson Billy Eichner upset in
the Ukraine
Denis burrows from hungry Brian
Escalante from Peru and Kasich orally
from than other ones and so yet and so
as you said maybe we can take a look at
the GM standings as all the games are
just about wrapped up here it looks like
we're going to have Dennis burrows in
clear first over took the lead from
giralda novel won a key game at they
went Brandon Jacobson also kid staying
in a very very big win for him and you
know Kate came back into the norm hunt
basically early and then the TF
unfortunately losing but still very much
having a very solid good tournament for
for results of the game is very good
fighting Chesley and Andrew hong-won a
nice game so he's also back in the noir
mix still having a chance it's it's
early you know any of these players
could kind even Bryan Escalante if he
wins all his games if I still
rattling at the norm and unfortunately
Casas is having a very soft turn but
let's hope that he has also his inner
strength in him to continue fighting and
playing good chess right maybe spoiling
some people's tournaments yeah that's
what role and maybe we can also take a
look at the standings for the I am
section of course you know oh by the way
you know by the way king of one was
indeed played I suspect so King f1 was
played in that game so we are expecting
a draw and this is not yet official but
this is the current position but here
both roca foreign King itsu leads two
drawers and sure you know you would
expect with five minutes you know good
player like guy you worry we'll figure
out the precise way to make a trophy and
so with that expected draw we actually
have the standings I think or flipping
around a lot here but it looks like yep
so we had a Luis Carlos in first place
with three points as kind of a mirror
image of the the GM section actually yes
trailing him our gari Aaron Jacobson
Keaton Kira and Eric Rosen actually and
Aaron and Keaton both moving up into
that second place position with a big
one today
and so again all these players pretty
much yeah once again the I am sorry not
make the the title holders are not
making it easy for the norm hunters
right yeah I've gotten the title for a
reason they've they've been through the
ringer they've you know certainly earned
it yes showing why they they won't have
it today they have to work hard first so
they want to make sure that the other
people also have to work hard for the
title which they as they should as they
should and in the game garage shows
another method to make a draw he played
the rock edge to wait simply defending
which is also totally fine and again
black took on have to here as we can see
live you know I expect white to take
back and now rook takes f2 should make a
draw yeah and again there's some
practical chances from from black if
you're playing a rookie player but it's
pretty great well with 30 second
increments in against a 20 a
against the in this kind of a tournament
we don't expect somebody to lose this
it's almost just a straight Philidor
position it is it is it is going to be a
Philidor position or although the roof
is gonna be on the third ring so maybe
it complicates things just a little bit
but even on the roof in a second there's
still you know still a drop of a very
big margin for error here so yeah with
that in mind that we're really expecting
a draw here I think we might just go
ahead and wrap up now and I think it was
an incredible around chest today so yeah
a lot of games that we weren't expecting
to be quite that interesting really uh
you know the players certainly showing
their fighting spirit especially you
know Jack sacrificing that piece trying
to make that end game into whatever he
could and you know of course the
Jacobson's continuing their there
running the tournament performing well
so with that in mind be sure to join us
tomorrow at 2 p.m.
once again Central Standard Time when we
start and that'll be a day for I do want
to mention something here
sure maybe after rook takes have to
maybe Brandon I mean Aaron will try King
Jitsu one last-minute trap hoping for
this and then suddenly Vlad gets the one
with opposition right but of course you
don't have to take it's chess not
checkers and you could just go King
Jitsu takes and King edge to and it's
still draw and position definite but I
think that actually there's nothing to
lose anyway so I think he will try King
g3 if this does happen okay so yeah so
tomorrow we'll be taking a look at all
the games once again you will still be
here Alex but unfortunately I will not
as Ben Simon will be reclaiming his
rightful role role as a host of the show
and so I'm sure all the Ben Simon fans
out there will be happy to hear that and
with that in mind yeah thank you so much
for joining us thank you for letting me
co-host with you Alex sure thanks I
think thanks for helping the broadcast
go much smoother and thanks everybody
for joining us we'll see you back
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you
you